[Music]
transformers and abused
in this video how quickly models for
video showing the face book went in the
press wie soll's und image netwaves 6
million parameter seventeen billion
flops improving typical city of
google is the english motto be done
that the sequence of patches becomes
transformers  not gone the not to the
patches of the photos from the tournament in the
transformation of pixie lott tm in and
models local and global information the
office of tea
the special olympics supermodels in
reality the super
bowl like herr much music on the waterfront
levels of gravity we  have the pixel victory
us she constantly represents in the
hole image as well as have
innotrans photoblog cinema the self engine
transformer magic in the pixel level
because like heaven autos formula block and
image petzschner will verdi image
patches euro presented at rector
same way previews work exactly the inner
and outer roads for the combined what
comes out on the ina transformer is
k  not in the lines project
fit people on the car transformer
representation widget is the patch
embedding before the professional at the cars
form so the cars formulas bulls
onpage level end representation statues
compute at tinnitus front and pixel
level and rehab the position however
changed locations  links in the image
which is not klier from the
salonen sector discussed transformers form
strongly recommend that really cool
stuff
[music]